77% of Americans both Republican and
Democrats believe that Biden is simply
too old to run the country almost 70%
think he's mismanaged the crisis at the
southern border does 133% say they're
financially better off on his watch at
this stage of his term he's the least
popular US president in recorded history
and this stuff matters us politics is in
almost hysterically polarized to the
rest of us outside America but most
voters are in fact ready to be persuaded
white working-class voters ditch the
Democrats to rep Trump to office in 2016
now more and more Hispanic and black
voters are shifting Republican too Biden
says he's the only man who's ever beaten
Trump and that's true but right now he
may be the only one who can lose to
Trump in November